[Musique]
bienvenue j'espère que vous avez tous
fait bon voyage merci d'être venu c'est
génial de te voir mon frère vous aurez
l'ensemble du complexe uniquement pour
vos invités et vous ce weekend qui
compte c'est nous vous pouvez être sûr
que c'est un weekend que vos invités et
vous n'oubliez jamais
ma wifi pas de réseau personne ne doit
sortir il retienne les invités en otages
dans le restaurant
je voulais et un homme riche et on se
demande combien vaut la vie de
fille
on s'aide mutuellement à traverser les
moments difficiles
où est-ce que tu vas faire mon travail
je tuerai chaque personne présente et je
ne saurais vous finir
tu pourras t'enfuir et aller chercher de
l'aide laisse-les partir tu peux me tuer
et laisse-les partir spectacle va
commencer
il fouille les tâche 5 secondes dans
chaque chambre